this is a production of cornell
university
yeah uh welcome back everybody
uh this is episode 18 of the cornell
turf show this year um our guest today
is matt elmore from records you'll
remember matt from
previous seasons coming on to chatweed's
uh as always we're never sure where
you're gonna lead us here frank and what
we're gonna get into today but for our
live audience uh you know you've always
got the the q a section so throw throw
questions at us whenever you see fit um
and i'll turn it over to you frank for
our little weather review this week yeah
and and you know uh we weren't we didn't
have our show yesterday we were out in
the field uh walking around golf courses
and you know just for other listeners
and viewers of the video or live
um you know we i i think there's
opportunities for us to walk around
outside and learn in a very uh low
stress uh no registration show up we'll
start talking we can walk around we'd
had a wonderful day yesterday out at the
links at greystone
uh with tim han and it was a good golf
group so today we're talking lawns and
you know the the
the funny thing about this conversation
over the last several years is you know
i have a weed scientist on and that used
to be all right control control control
and now we're having this broader
discussion about the the flowering lawn
so i know that's going to be part of our
conversation today that's the wild car
for today matt but we're gonna we're
gonna we got some more traditional
things more like what carl's dog is
doing to his backyard uh this i don't
even think your backyard looks this good
does it oh i would wish for this frank
that's right but you can see the bombs
this little guy's been dropping uh
through the winter time and you know
being so far behind as we're going to
talk about in a minute this slug of
nitrogen really shows up and shows you
how you can overcome some of these
things if you're willing to do fertilize
the way we did back in the 60s you know
at 10 pounds of nitrogen
on a lawn per thousand square feet so
all right carl here's your stat i know
you're going flowering lawns what are we
talking about
yeah and i thought it was it was apropos
today you know we talk about weeds and
like you said frank we're always
controlling them
i think this study from minnesota is is
maybe um quantifying the shift in the
american public and and how they uh
value pollinators
right so pollinator lawns commonly you
can find lawn mixes now in in the big
box stores that that have white clover
self-heal
um some of these flowering weeds that
the pollinators can forage on and gives
them
uh some food so so these folks in
minnesota went around to a bunch of
neighborhood parks
um they had some some pollinator lawns
set up and they asked people you know
what do you think of pollinator lawns do
you support these
uh and overwhelmingly people said they
did and then they would follow up and
say you know okay there's going to be
more pollinators that's a higher
likelihood of getting stung by
a pollinator do you still support
these these areas even when you may get
more likely to get stung even then 95
percent of people they surveyed were in
support so i think that's kind of
showing you where we're moving towards
um you can buy pollinator mixes you can
you can plant those things this picture
over here is is mylon which was not
planted and that's just
wild violet and dandelion and the
pollinators like that i'm again as i've
documented i'm a lazy homeowner so this
is kind of uh born out of my laziness
and not wanting to mow more than 10
times a year um but but i can feel good
that there's uh there's foraging habitat
for the pollinators
so so we're seeing more of that for sure
yeah and carl i'll tell you i was in
madison you know madison wisconsin the
ithaca of the midwest if you will
um
and i would say uh 35 of the lawns
looked exactly like this
um you know there's not enormous
diversity in a lot of lawns it's it's
dandelion these are violets right the
violets are uh really in bloom you might
see some ground ivy here and there uh
coming in going in different places but
um this yeah i saw i don't know where
everybody's going with this but for sure
the season is very far behind
uh not everybody's mode further north
the dry conditions that i'm going to
talk about in a second has slowed a lot
of things but not necessarily uh what we
would call weeds right so let's look at
the weather and matt i got some
questions for you as we get into the
weather a little bit particularly uh
when we talk about dandelion control but
overall we'll start with moisture that's
a pretty big story you can see the
really strong gradient it's much drier
to the north we're at 50 to 75 of normal
once you get north of the pennsylvania
border up the hudson valley pioneer
valley and especially along the new
england coast and the eastern end of
long island and you can see already in
the drought monitor some of these places
are starting to show up as as getting
pretty dry and that's in addition to the
cooler weather um you know slowing down
normal growth now the other thing you
notice and this was a wow we're starting
to see et values above an inch here we
are in the end of may is so the sun's
got another six weeks or so to get the
peak height in the sky where where e.t
values will be really high so you're
probably seeing a lot of things drying
out and of course this is going to have
a big effect on uh on
on turf growth moving forward now um
last week you can see this wall
that got built right across pennsylvania
and across the northern uh you know
central massachusetts area where there
was very little rainfall to the north
and as much as two inches probably where
you are matt uh you got a dump last week
and so looking forward again everybody
for the next day or two is going to get
dry and then it looks like we're moving
into a
showery period for the weekend but
no real strong patterns here art our
climatologist was indicating on thursday
that it's about a 50 50 how the rainfall
is going to go he's going to call it he
was calling it overall less than a half
an inch uh region-wide so we're not
expecting to see uh widespread heavy
rainfall like we did the last couple of
weeks so the roller coaster uh continues
this doesn't have some of the high
temperatures um that we experience later
in the week particularly in the north
and overall we still finished a little
bit below normal and only slightly above
normal and that's because we started out
cool before the heat came
mid last week now looks like again we're
going to be normal temperatures maybe a
couple of spikes uh over the weekend
while the showers are coming through but
overall a normal you know 40 to 50s for
lows 60 to 70s for highs
for the week forward temperature wise so
the degree days now is where the weed
story begins to emerge because you look
at degree days over the last week you
see still less than 20
in the northern part of the region and
you go to the south where it's been a
little bit warmer you can see as much as
50 to 60 right so that's still
barely 10 degrees a day that's being
accumulated and you look at the
difference from normal since the growing
season started as we market march 15th
we still have a majority of the
northeast well behind normal
as much as two weeks when you get into
the northern areas
but at higher elevations a little a
little further behind and as you get
around the new york metropolitan area a
little bit closer to normal the stats
are that from last year we're about two
weeks behind and about one week behind
in general the 30-year normal so
matt the vanderlines are starting to
bloom this is when everybody wants to
treat him just a a ground check with you
on this oh i wanted to introduce you did
you know you had a new title now
we don't call you a weed scientist
anymore we've decided to call these
plants incidental flowering plants not
weeds we feel that's a little too harsh
on these plants that their virtue hasn't
been realized yet so we're going to
leave you with this how do you like this
purdue model
this is really right to be sure it's a
narrow 24d
dandelion spring have you played around
with this at all i know you worked with
braz i don't know if you guys played
around with this but this was developed
back in the riker throssell days and we
put it up there as a guideline but i
want to get your thoughts on
yeah i think it's it's definitely a good
guideline um i think the other thing to
be aware of or to at least be
monitoring is you know the flowering um
sometimes control can be a little bit
lower at flowering but in general two
you know dandelions are if you want to
control them are pretty easily
controlled with you know your 2 4 d type
products
i think the key is
you know looking at a map like this
where hey is it too early right now
and not applying when it's too early
so you know for if you get up into new
england it's still a little bit early
right now here we're at the
i guess you'd call puffball stage um
so it's you know getting to be a good
window for us to treat
based on that and also basically
yeah there's some other work that shows
that
you know again they can be a little bit
tougher to control at flowering but you
know
practically speaking that's
a little bit tough to do right i mean
whenever everyone's making these
applications they're in the springtime
you know they're flowering and i think
the key thing to remember is that
dandelions are
relatively easy to control with
you know your typical
24d products okay so just getting it you
know maybe avoid and the other reason to
avoid flowering is
we're talking about spraying the
pollinators yeah yeah if you want to
wait right now i mean the dandelions
have done most of their flowering so
you know the pollinators have enjoyed
them and i guess now
it's time to move on to something else
so
uh if you want to go ahead and spray
those dandelions i guess right you you
you know you you're uh you've given the
pollinators the chance right
of course
it's a perennial so next year's crop
won't be as strong if you spray them
this year i guess that's one thing to
keep in mind if that's the goal of your
of your you know lawn sports field
management whatever it is i mean they do
re-establish from seed but you know they
are perennials so right and and again
that's why we tell people this ain't the
time
the time is the fall right that's the
ideal time the problem is people see
them now yeah yeah right
so you can get more thorough control
uh of the
of the bigger plants especially right
later in the season and then preventing
that flowering potentially from
occurring
for sure and we've done work here
um even into november we've gotten good
control december was too late
um but you know
that window in the fall is pretty large
yeah and and deep control so so listen
let's move on to the next patch of weeds
that are then going to be impacted by
soil temperature which you can see
you know
we had in the 60s like a month ago and
it's like we pushed pause and it would
go up for a few days and then down well
when we would be record lows and it
looks like now almost everybody's in the
50s some have crept into the low 60s
which starts to say okay
what about crabgrass germination and my
pre so you know i pulled the gdd
prediction uh of this and it looks like
germination is actively underway where
you are uh matt what do you say how do
you lie i mean i think the forsythias
are
green now right oh yeah for sure yeah
we're long past that um we're getting
rhododendron starting to bloom now okay
um but yeah so
i agree with that map we've already seen
crabgrass emergence in some of the
thinner areas you know where the
sunlight is going to heat up that soil a
little bit quicker that's been
probably about two or three weeks ago
but then the crabgrass that came up
you know two or three weeks ago just
kind of sitting there and wondering
maybe
that came up a little bit early
but
i i think we're going to get a big flush
of germination when we get this warm up
next week and now that we've got wet
soils um you know i think this map's
looking looking pretty good here so
all right yeah all right we haven't had
our big flush yet but but for sure the
priest should be out by now and in this
region and
yeah right and you know me i've been
trying to challenge the pre-emergent
idea for a really long time right the
blanket applications that you know we do
so we've been playing around as you know
some alternatives and it started out
with some impact of traffic
on crabgrass right this is without the
availability of pre-emergent herbicides
that this golf course doesn't have um we
found uh some from uh jim watson back in
the 50s chris sitko uh uncovered this
publication that indicated that uh
under heavy compaction crab grass was
not germinating as well
this was one of the only reports
i think i've ever seen of this uh where
heavy compaction
suppressed crabgrass germination so
we started playing around with this
a couple of years ago during the
pandemic we were locked up so we started
driving back and forth on our plots uh
this is rolling two times a day five
days a week with a golf cart and uh uh
obviously to light a roller coaster the
tires did most of the work here and this
is a picture map we took uh 12 months
after we stopped the treatments
so this you know we stopped the
treatments in the fall of the previous
year and this is right around august a
year later now um
you look close and you can see we get
much less crabgrass there and then when
chris sitko was working out at the
vineyard last year uh he took an area
and just started rolling it every day
uh six days a week
looks like we sprayed it right this was
really uh quite impressive in ways that
we don't entirely understand uh yet
other than what watson showed um the
other thing we've done that and i know
you've played around with this too but
these are plots from chris's work last
year where he sprayed fiesta at full
rate
early post one to five leaf crab grass
on a blue grass practice tee
sandy soils
and it was dry right after he made a
single application so you're looking at
an august picture
from a single application made in june
so this is driving me crazy
yeah you know trying to put all this
together so let's start with just a
general conversation about this this
craziness that we're seeing and what
your alternative work has started to
bear out or not for crabgrass control
yeah well the rolling uh work is really
interesting and all that compaction
stuff we're planning to start some work
this year looking at that with goose
grass we have the plots laid out and
everything
and then we've also been looking at
fiesta as well and seen similar things
where that early post-emergence timing
seems to be pretty good so for us that's
you know june
um we get into july
and there's a little too much
phytotoxicity with that application
and then pre-emergence we have not seen
it work well as a true pre so just like
you uh and chris up there you know we're
seeing similar things and it's not
as much control as we get from synthetic
products but the whole idea is we're
trying to find an alternative and build
an integrated program so
these two things
you know layered together
look like they could be
pretty effective and potentially you
know especially if you think about the
fact that we're already doing a lot of
rolling anyway on some of these areas
that's right and maybe we'll get people
out rolling their customers lawns yeah
uh at certain times of the year right or
going out with this now now um
uh i want to keep going because this
theme isn't over right so you know every
year we scientists uh do their survey
right and we get our this is our turf
grass uh most common and most
troublesome and i know you probably
would agree with uh almost all of these
although the ones that worry me
are uh nuts edge and probably kylinga
for you
but i want to add to this because you
got me thinking about this a while ago
right you made a statement that maybe
we're starting to see plants elude our
traditional pre-strategies here is on
the left the japanese stilt grass that
you said i think you said it germinated
what six weeks ago
five weeks ago
yeah we um
i'd have to check this year i believe it
was it was we actually have
pre-emergence trials now out for still
grass and we put them out in mid-march
so i believe it was early april this
year it's been a little cool
right i'm not exactly sure though i have
to check but yeah much earlier up to a
month earlier right maybe six weeks if
we get a warm year you know this year
has been really steady some years we get
these wild fluctuations where it gets up
to you know 75 degrees in march for
three days and that'll trigger a lot of
these weeds to you know like still grass
to germinate so
yeah we're we're
i agree that there's
you know there's certain species finding
a niche in our holes in our strategy
so
i think we're a little bit scared about
this um
still grass on one level we'll get the
goose grass in a second but the steel
grass
a c4
yeah warm season plant with shade
tolerance
that's a little bit concerning from uh
when you think of woodline edges and
this is a picture of a shady lawn uh
typically you wouldn't go out early with
a pre and i'm thinking okay well what if
they're trying to get still grass and
crab grass if they put their crabgrass
material out in march
to get stiltgrass and get that crabgrass
are they going to have to go out with
another pre to get the goose grass
that's going to come later man
so is this going to mean we need two
pres
or do you see i can find one pre to get
all three of these well i think it's a
good opportunity to use the split
applications split up split application
program you know making two apps but
taking that total active ingredient and
dividing it into two
the other thing i think it's an
opportunity to i mean it depends on your
business model but trying to get more
site-specific management because i don't
think we're going to see goose grass in
the same places we'll see still grass i
some anecdotally what we've seen is
still grass is kind of like crabgrass it
doesn't really like those high traffic
areas whereas goose grass that's really
mostly where it's competitive it's not
going to be competitive in these low
traffic areas
you know in our goose grass plots at the
farm or we don't traffic then we pretty
much we have to spray the crabgrass out
otherwise the crabgrass will just choke
out the goose grass so when you shift
and you get these you know highly
compacted areas you almost need to have
a separate program for that maybe
compared to these low traffic areas
where you might get still grass and
crabgrass again that's one potential
option that doesn't fit every
every business model but yeah i agree
our our pre
you know the window where we need a
pre-emergent out there
this is probably a little bit larger if
we've got can you talk a little bit more
about split apps you're not are you
talking
two full rate apps or you're talking
find the rate i mean do
a lot of the pres we would be using
again let's review them maybe
pendimethalim prodiamine di thiopeir
those would be the big ones right that
you would normally
see used in the lawn landscape maybe
team
if but that's not very long lived yeah
so so are we going to be able to get
these
how are we going to split these apps
yeah
i mean we've done some work looking at
applications even in february for crab
grass control which would be a good
timing for still grass as well and when
you apply in february
late february as soon as the soil thaws
out
you get less control from a single app
and
good you know as much control as you
would from a normally timed app if you
apply in february and then again
in mid
june and and that's splitting the taking
the full rate and splitting it in two so
we're not doing two full rate apps we're
taking in the high rate which for
dimension is half a pound
for diamine a pound of active again so
it depends on the product and then penta
methylene three pounds so we're taking
that we're either putting it out in one
shot in february which again is going to
cover stilt grass but it kind of runs
out of gas
for crab grass but if you take that
three pounds let's say a pentameter and
split it into two apps one in february
or early march for still grass control
and then you come back again
in late may early june um that worked
well for crabgrass control again
compared to single apps so this is great
this is great now but once i do that am
i done being able to patch seed or any
over seeding and what if like a lot of
companies sell aeration in the spring
yeah for the spring you're not gonna be
able to see
yeah you're not gonna be able to see it
in the spring
if you're aerating in the spring
i'm
based on some of the work that was done
at michigan state in the 80s and all
that and some of the work we've done
recently if you've got good turf or if
the compaction the soil is compromising
the ability of the turf to grow i
wouldn't be afraid to aerate even if
you've applied a pre
the way that the herbicide moves in the
soil wouldn't say moves but you know
kind of equilibrates in the soil you're
not really it's not like
but the barrier theory and punching a
hole in that is maybe a little bit
oversimplified that's right uh i think
it's a good way to think about it but i
wouldn't worry about
you know breaking that barrier yeah no
because i you know it was just to say it
stays resident it just you know just
puts up shop yeah exactly for about 10
to 12 weeks
uh you know and remains in some uh
active form so listen let me keep going
because i got two more to go here and
one is this weed
nutsedge are we ever going to be able to
actually completely control this because
i'm worried this thing which is common
and keeps bubbling up and we've only got
one line of products in the northeast
uh this thing is going to be
uncontrollable soon what are your
thoughts on this nutsedge control yeah
um
i it's very difficult to control
especially
when we have these wet years i mean last
year we've had a lot of years now where
we haven't really had
the dry periods and that helps
um we've had a lot of warm temperatures
that thins out turf late in the summer
which you know all that work recently
out of nebraska shows how much more
competitive this weed is in a thin stand
to turf so late in the summer i think
the thing
with this one is
you know it's going to be a multi-year
strategy whatever you need to do
because those tubers it produces
underground are just so
persistent so
we've been looking at earlier
applications what's the best program for
a couple of year control how do i i
think looking at it's going to be a
multi multiple application program and
almost knowing where it was the year
before so you can
make that application relatively early
and then make another one you know six
to eight weeks later so i'm talking
something maybe
even early june um
make an application of you know your
halo sulfuron or your pyramid sulfan
or your mesosulfuranzo solero
sedgehammer or vexus some of those we
don't have in new york i don't think
right yeah you have a paleosulfuron
that's it that's it yeah and you don't
even have sulfentrazine which is the
alternative mode of action
um so yeah it's more challenging for you
in new york where you've only got halo
sulfur huh so you like two apps yeah
six weeks apart start in early june yeah
yeah as soon as you can see it because
it starts to produce tubers you know
just four to six weeks after you see
those shoots so it's setting next year's
crop
you know not too long after those come
up so and those tubers can persist for
several years so that's why you know
just like crabgrass you know you need to
be
you need to kind of know what's in the
seed bank or you need to know what
tubers are in the soil it's going to
take a long time
to really get it under control
what about the addition of uh a
methylated seed oil or crop seed oil
what do you like about that yeah nis
non-ionic surfactant for halo sulfuron
is really critical you know you could
potentially
double your herbicide
efficacy just by adding that surfactant
that's a key thing i think a lot of
people
don't know or you know it's on the label
but they're you know there's a million
dollars why don't they okay
this has been true about products with
since bastagran basta grand worked
better when you put methylated seed oil
in it why don't they just put that stuff
in the herbicide
yeah
i don't completely understand why they
don't either i don't know if it's i
think it's difficult to formulate it in
there sometimes and
you know i've i've hear various answers
to that question i'm not
i'm not don't know that i don't know i
guess all right it would be nice
listen we're going to wrap this up with
the hardest question
how do i manage quote unquote weeds
in a flowering lawn
it's a million dollar question
i mean i i don't think we have a lot of
good answers
i don't know about you i think it's
gonna come down to
you know you're not gonna be spraying
herbicides that's for sure at least not
post-emergence herbicides broadly for
besides
um you're not gonna blanket i think what
i would say is you're moving to a
complete spot treatment now because the
diversity of plant material you have
um
is is going to restrict i mean you can't
keep one broad leaf well here's the
thing let's take on clover law let's say
people just went the simple route out of
the gate and went clover the first thing
i tell them is just buy something with
24d in it because 240 doesn't control
clover you can get some of those other
plants out of there that's a simple way
to approach it isn't it matt yeah for
sure yeah that's the simplest version if
you do still want some control over the
species that are in there for sure it'll
it'll
suppress clover a little bit so i'd like
we talked about dandelion wait till it's
past that flowering stage which comes
you know in a couple weeks
but yeah it's not gonna 240 or won't
kill clover so at least not if applied
properly all right carl we got any
questions from the live audience
uh just a note from ben palmer who said
anecdotally uh he sees more goose grass
than than crabgrass in his highly
compacted sports fields
um so i think that tracks with
some things we've seen i think the
comment i i'll make frank is we're
talking about different weeds and
different control strategies you may
need different products
uh and it may sound like um even if you
don't have a pollinator lawn if you
don't want to use a whole lot of
chemicals if you've got all these
different weeds some in the shade some
out in the open okay i'm spraying five
four three herbicide applications is
that going to be bad i think to matt's
point if you're spot specific
you know if you're not treating the
entire yard three times uh you know this
idea of pesticide risk that can be an
ipm practice if you're only spraying the
shady areas for
um for your stilt grass and then you're
using different products but on a
smaller site specific basis
in in total that can be less risk than
if you're going to do that that blanket
application so i think just making that
point is is important for people to know
that that using chemicals in in certain
areas uh again turf cover is the
ultimate goal here right and you may
only need to do it two years
um some of these may be longer you know
than that such i think and you know i
think this is where like large
institutional grounds commercial grounds
uh campuses
uh municipal buildings things you know
where there's a group of people that are
resident that care for it all the time
there really isn't any excuse to not do
site specific it's just let's just
blanket the whole place that's i think
what we got to start moving away from
and if we don't somebody's going to make
us move away from it i think especially
in new york but matt the challenge as
we've talked about with cal bigelow carl
a couple weeks ago was do you you work a
lot with lawn care providers
professional lawn care applicators do
you see them moving to more
site-specific applications or you see
them going out and blanketing and
split-apping and going that route versus
site-specific stuff
i've talked to some that are trying to
get more site-specific
i think it depends on
i think one thing
that
you know the decision makers whether
they're administrators or whatever you
need to start considering is let's not
just go
with the lowest bid let's go with
someone who's going to provide what we
want so let's ask put in that contract
you know i want site specific management
whatever and
you know hopefully there's some people
that can do that
you know so i don't really blame the
applicators or the companies or whatever
they're just uh you know competing and
so i think no one's demanding it yeah no
one's demanding i mean even on our
campus
they're we're we're not you know asking
that of our our contract
and i'll tell you the thing one of the
greatest innovations i think happened
was that buggy that these long guys
drive around these things they got
granular they can spot treat sometimes
they've got a little boom in front
they've got a wand on it as well so it
looks like they have the equipment
uh to do it in many cases
and i just i i'm with you there you know
that the way the market is run the
contracts aren't written
to to foster or encourage this type of
uh commercial service at least it's not
been my experience and i don't know how
to help with that because we can't get
the
general consumer to understand almost
the basic things of how stuff works
never mind uh this sort of management so
listen matt thanks for chatting it's
always a highlight of my time when i get
to chat with a fellow weed scientist so
appreciate the work that you do and
taking the time to join us uh appreciate
that carl
yep thanks again matt for joining us
today uh we'll be back again next week
with our our last week of episodes uh
this year we're gonna have one more golf
episode on thursday and and one more
sports uh episode on friday so until
then uh we'll see you all have a good
weekend this has been a production of
cornell university on the web at
cornell.edu